the interviewer also asked John Kerry
about Davos and the private jets and all
the fancy meat that they eat and all
that stuff and here's just general
gobbley by John Kerry private
Aviation is is an example of something
where people are starting to pay more
attention and
um but when uh you know people who go to
Davos to talk about climate change fly
private it seems like they don't want to
make uh they actually I've talked to
them about it they offset they buy
offsets they offset and they are working
harder than most people I know to be
able to try to affect this transition
right oh that is horse you
horse-faced buffoon he looks like a
horse doesn't he something he I always
say he looks like a tree who are the
trees in uh Lord of the Rings again and
and is the name of a tree or it was they
were all trees it's the type of species
thank you this is Connor's nail in it
today in a new studio he doesn't forget
any of his Lord of the Rings references
he looks like an IT the man is becoming
a tree he's so into green stuff he's
actually becoming a tree but he also
looks a little bit like a horse but
putting all that aside uh carbon officer
this is exactly the same stuff that Bill
Gates does Bill Gates buys all the
Farmland doesn't want you to eat meat
they don't want you to fly on a plane
they fly on airplanes if you think for
one second that John Kerry or Leonardo
DiCaprio or Bill Gates or any of these
people will ever give up their luxuries
you are crazy they will never give them
up and not only that and I've been
around some pretty wealthy people you
have no idea the level of wealth that
these have these people have in the
things they can get away with and if you
think that that Bill Gates during covet
he had all of his servants masked up I'm
sure while he lived however he wanted it
is four it is just a way of controlling
you we have carbon officers they pay
their my
[Music]
thank you